ننقل لكم المشهد والصوره هنا من مجزره
كبيره جدا حصلت في الفالوجه في شمال قطاع
غزه تحديدا في مخيم جباليه اقف الان وسط
هذه الجثت من الشهداء التي تتجاوز 80
شهيدا في هذا المنزل الذي يعود لابو طارق
ابو علبه في حي الفالوجه هذا العدد الكبير
والكبير جدا من الشهداء والجثث التي اقفوا
في وسطها الان انقل لكم المشهد وال
من قلب هذه الجت والشهداء رحمه الله عليهم
هذا الاحتلال الهمجي الاسرائيلي الذي
ارتكب هذه المتزره في حق عائله ابو علبه
في مخيم جباليه الفالوجه هذه اشلاء وجت
لاطفال اقف هنا بجوانب طفله شهيده هنا
اشلاء كبيره جدا يعني كما تشاهدون هذه هي
جتت الشهداء كما تشاهدون و يعني في كل
مكان ارصد لكم المشهد والصوره من قلب هذا
المنزل المتزره الكبيره التي حلت في منزل
عائله ابو علبه التي تتجاوز اكثر من 80
شهيدا في هذا المنزل في مخيم جباليا ننقل
لكم المشهد والصوره من وسط هذه
الجت